acht wochen auf mallorca klingt nach dem
traum eines jeden deutschen urlaubers
eigentlich für die kegelbrüder wurde
dieser aber zum alptraum sie saßen jetzt
57 tage in untersuchungshaft
und jetzt endlich sind sie alle freie
kommen auf kaution frei zurück in
deutschland wird ihre ankunft von
freunden und familie gefeiert hier sehen
wir sie umringt von der familie von
freunden endlich sind diese 57 tage im
mallorquinischen knast beendet hier wird
gewunken hier werden sie auf dem
flugfeld bereits in empfang genommen
das sind die fröhlichen bilder nach
diesen horror tagen auf mallorca
[Musik]
liga
[Applaus]
man gelassen
freiheit boden kontakt mit der heimat
nach acht wochen des leidens der
ungewissheit und der angst
der empfang am flughafen bei münster
euphorisch
ein vater der brüder holt sie auf
mallorca ab fliegt mit ihnen zurück nach
deutschland
natürlich
schon das erste video aus hände bekommen
von den vielen leuten die hier sind und
in den anflug der jungs hier begleitet
haben und
emotion pur
beschreiben möchte dann ist das genau
diese situation wir gerade passiert das
unglaubliche acht wochen sitzen die
kegelbrüder im mallorquinischen knast am
freitagabend dann endlich ihre ersten
schritte in freiheit
warum auf einmal die entlassung nach
bild informationen lägen die anwälte der
kegelbrüder dem spanischen gericht in
den letzten tagen nachweise über deren
wohnsitze und arbeitsverträge vor diese
sind nun ins spanische übersetzt das
wertet die staatsanwaltschaft als neuen
umstand der die fluchtgefahr verringert
die kegelbrüder kommen auf kaution frei
aber komplett von allen problemen
befreit sind die jungs noch nicht der
gerichtsprozess steht erst noch an es
wird weiter gegen die deutschen
ermittelt weiß auch die anwältin der
angeklagten gibt noch viel zu tun
und das wird heute also das wird
wahrscheinlich in den nächsten monaten
nicht ändern sondern dass wir brauchen
viel zeit um das alles mit
rückblende zwanzigster mai diesen jahres
die wiimote mallorca steht in flammen
das inferno zerstört auch ein darunter
liegendes bordell der vorwurf der
spanischen justiz die kegelbrüder die in
dem hotel daneben wohnen haben brennende
zigarettenstummel auf das reetdach der
bar geschnippt und so den brand
ausgelöst
die jungs werden festgenommen landen in
u haft jetzt sind sie also endlich
wieder frei samstagfrüh stehen die
kegelbrüder auf dem flughafen von
mallorca können ihren heimflug kaum noch
erwarten
[Musik]
ausreise in letzter sekunde denn die
gesamte spanische justiz geht in den
kommenden tagen für vier wochen in die
sommerpause
freilassungen in dieser zeit keine
chance fast wären aus acht wochen knast
sogar noch zwölf geworden glück im
unglück die erleichterung umso größer
[Applaus]
und auch wenn der prozess gegen die
jungs noch aussteht in den
mallorquinischen knast müssen sie wohl
nicht noch einmal von innen sehen nein
dort kann muss nicht ausliefern es gibt
keine rütteltest harfe fälligen die
gegen die jungs sie kommen auf freien
fuß und bleiben da und führen ein
normales leben als ob nicht ein
verfahren nicht jetzt ist hier wurde wir
können uns vollends vor ort ja freiheit
der horror ist vorbei
jetzt drücken wir den kegelbrüdern die
daumen dass ihre unschuld bewiesen
werden kann denn dann wird ein weiteres
mal
unser bild reporter jörg völkerling hat
den fall wie kein zweiter für uns
verfolgt jörg 57 tage im gefängnis wir
haben die bilder gesehen von der
freilassung von der familie von den
freunden wir haben die kegelbrüder auf
dich gewirkt
ja ein riesen stein ist ihnen vom herzen
gefallen auch wenn dieses
damoklesschwert weiter über ihnen
schwebt aber man muss sich vorstellen
sie sind fest verankerte jungs die in
der landwirtschaft gearbeitet haben die
in der freiwilligen feuerwehr aktiv
waren die sozial verankert sind die sich
vorher nie was zu schulden kommen lassen
haben und teilweise auch noch nie in
ihrem leben in dem flugzeug saßen
mallorca die drei tage das sollte
wirklich ein ausbruch aus dem alltag
werden und ist dann wirklich so ein
drama geworden für sie
es war einfach grenzenlose erleichterung
sie haben geweint im auto des paares das
pfarrerehepaar das evangelische dass
dort auf mallorca arbeitet hat uns das
geschildert sie haben ihnen die handys
gegeben weil ihre eigenen handys immer
noch beschlagnahmt sind von der justiz
damit sie erst mal nach hause
telefonieren können und dann haben sie
ihn ihren ersten wunsch erfüllt das war
einfach mal wieder eine pizza zu essen
sie haben ein bierchen ausgegeben und
die ganze nacht das waren nur sehr kurze
nacht von der haftentlassung bis zum
abflug kein auge mehr zugedrückt
57 tage lang saßen sie in
untersuchungshaft warum hat das so lange
gedauert
das hat glaube ich sehr viel mit der
person des untersuchungsrichters antonio
hodgers zu tun der als sehr hartnäckig
als sehr streng wie auf mallorca gilt
der viele beweise eigentlich anfangen
schon zum anfang auf dem tisch hatte zum
beispiel auch dieses bekannt gewordene
whatsapp foto wo man 2 von den
kegelbrüdern auf einem sehr weit von dem
brandort entfernten balkon sieht und
hinter ihnen einen unbekannten mann der
sehr viel näher an diesem schiff dach
steht und möglicherweise auch eine
zigarette in der hand hat dieser mann
ist bis heute nicht mehr vernommen
worden und man fragt sich schon warum
die guardia civil auf mallorca sich so
schnell auf diese 13 jungs eingeschossen
hat bei diesem vorwurf ohne vorsatz
während die in deutschland niemals im
gefängnis gelandet ganz unabhängig von
der schuldfrage und es bedurfte dann
viele anläufe eine halbe million euro
muss zusammen gesammelt werden als
solidarhaftung um diesen schaden erst
mal sozusagen abzusichern auch wenn gar
nicht klar ist ob diese jungs wirklich
die den schaden verursacht haben und
dann haben die anwälte einen glücklichen
umstand ausgenutzt der richter war ende
vergangener woche im urlaub einige in
justizkreisen sagen bild auch er wurde
quasi gedrängt urlaub zu nehmen damit er
das gesicht wahren kann in dieser ganzen
affäre und seine vertretungs richterin
hat dann den freilassung befehl
sozusagen unterschrieben die
staatsanwaltschaft auch das brisant
hatte wohl schon anfang juni hätte eine
entlassung auf kaution 12.000 euro wie
bei den anderen vier die damals
freigelassen wurden schon zugestimmt und
so kam es jetzt dazu dass sie nach acht
wochen endlich nach hause gehen konnten
und man kann schon unter dem strich
sagen ohne dass wirklich jetzt die
objektivität aus dem auge zu verlieren
das ist schon ein kleiner justizskandal
der tat zu ende geht auf jeden fall und
ist auch noch nicht zuende jörg
völkerling du verfolgst den fall für uns
weiterhin vielen dank für den